was there ever a person that
the street thought was the power player
but behind closed doors in the mob the
person that really held it all together
that everybody feared was XYZ was that
that person in your world yes who was
that person that was Chin giganti Chin
was yeah okay got it everybody thought
it was uh Tony Salerno who was the boss
but it was really chin he was the power
in all of New York at that time
and and you think there are chins in
every space
I think so yeah I do absolutely
that we don't know about that we don't
know about you think there's a chin to
Murdoch
well you know
that's kind of tough I mean who's gonna
tell him what to do you know I don't
know about that really
the older Murdoch I'm talking not the
young not the young ones no um yeah you
think there's a chin to Sorrows or you
think Soros is chin I think Soros is
chin but he's the difference with chin
chin didn't want anybody to know who he
was Soros is out there I mean what this
guy does now I don't think there's
anybody pulling the strings on him I
think he's the guy got it so no one's
pulling the soul who is the chin of the
right
God who's the Sorrows of the right
that's hard to say Patrick
really
who do you think it is who's the who's
the chin of the right I mean Soros who's
out there you know it you see his impact
yeah he's happening on this country
I don't know if you talk about from a
financial standpoint You could argue
that the Koch brothers were there that's
where Sheldon Adelson passed away
possibly him I mean these guys were
given
multi-millions if not billions of
dollars now this is what musk said about
Soros yesterday
he said Soros reminds me of Magneto
okay and then uh Brian responds back uh
if you can put show more because he goes
into it pretty and then Elon responds
back again he says fun fact Magneto's
experiences during the Holocaust as a
Survivor shape this perspective as well
as his depth and empathy sorrow Sorrows
also a holocaust Survivor gets attacked
non-stop for his good intentions with
some Americans think are bad merely
because they disagree with his political
affiliation then look at what musk
responds back with you assume they are
good intentions they are not he wants to
erode the very fabric of civilization
Soros hates Humanity anyways they go
back and forth on how he views uh Soros
yeah I'd be curious to know who who the
current Soros is on the right yeah but
you know you see the impact of Soros you
know I think it was 2010 when something
happened to the Supreme Court he didn't
get a good decision and he publicly
stated he said it's going to be my
mission to destroy America he said it he
said it publicly and you can see his in
influence all over the country is he is
destroying America he's taking a big
part in that I don't see that on the
right I don't see even the Koch brothers
okay financially they got but what is
their influence what are they doing that
you can see that's so influential I
don't see it I don't see that on the
right well I think on the left you can
see it I think without a doubt the chin
to use an example is
by Far and Away Donald Trump at this
point and he's pulling all the strings
on the right I'm not saying
behind the scenes I'm saying in front of
the camera Maga making the moves that no
you don't think that Donald Trump
controls the right these days no you
don't think so no no because the the DNA
of a chin is they're never on camera
and what you're saying behind the scenes
I'll tell you I'll tell you how I
learned that's what I think Patrick I
when I was in the gas business I had uh
you know when you're making that kind of
money on the street everybody starts
looking at you and I had a little
trouble with my boss with Persico at the
time and it was kind of known nothing
big but it was it was brewing right well
the chin sense for me I'd never met him
but he sends for me and I go see him
we're walking on Houston Street messed
up hair bathrobe exactly like you know
they portrayed him and we're walking up
and down and he said you know I got all
respect for your father and somebody
introduced me to him that that spoke
very well about me and he said I heard
you're having some trouble with persical
a person who was a boss or the Columbus
I swell chin it's okay he said if you
got a problem he should come over here
and you'll be a captain with me
now I'm saying to myself that's the boss
of a family he's talking about and I
said well you know junior he said did
you hear what I said
I said anytime you want you leave there
you come over here you're a captain in
my family
and the way he said it to me I said
that's when I realized this guy really
is the power no doubt yeah yeah
yeah
I I think every industry has a chin
and I said I think the best chins don't
want you to know who the chin is the
ultimate chin right now in the world is
who who's the ultimate Schwab maybe
actually if you think about the ultimate
chin and and I know this is going to be
what are you talking about the ultimate
not the ultimate ship he's not the
ultimate I'm about to talk about but the
ultimate Way of being a chin today is uh
the founder of Bitcoin Satoshi no come
on nobody has a clue who he is no but
he's pulling the strings you know he's
he's uh it's it's a DNA of somebody that
you don't know what the you know he just
kind of dances and things are getting
done he's the last phone call people
make well do you see that person on the
right
I I speculate a couple names but I I
don't see somebody today and I think
quite frankly I think
that's not really good I don't think
it's really good because I think the
right chin is also able to be a
synergist and keep people together
because you think about what Soros is
doing Soros is helping the left I was
going to say I wish we had one yeah
right I think Soros is a help in the
left uh I think you saw what happened
with musk yesterday with the story that
came out did you see the story that came
out with musk yesterday right after he
hires the NBC Universal lady uh uh uh
Linda I have a hard time saying her last
name your car you know yakari or sorry
you know something like that this report
comes out the document subpoena and
Jeffrey Epstein's lawsuit by U.S Virgin
Islands JP Morgan Chase
etc etc Tesla alphabet all these guys
they're you know the U.S Virgin Islands
as subpoena Tesla see Obama documents
and Slauson JPMorgan Chase helping
sexual relatives I mean Jeffrey see to
me now this right here
ha this this is when you know
you're not shin
musk is not chin no they want to ignore
all the names on the left that
associated with Epstein yeah but now
immediately to go after the most yeah
they they they want to
I don't know man I I
it's those weird phone calls that you
get you know the the whole weird phone
calls you get where they say hey
um uh just so you know I have XYZ on you
okay I have this on you don't forget we
have access to your computer and we know
what you watch we know your search
engine we know what you look at on your
phone
remember that one time your phone
crashed it wasn't that your phone
crashed we got into your phone we've
been monitoring everybody been texting
with every Everybody you've been uh
dming with all the pictures you've sent
the couple Brett Favre type attacks
you've sent we have access to all your
Brett Favre tap attacks you know we have
these videos we have that and then all
of a sudden like what yes kind of like J
Ed groover type of stuff when the mob
you guys went up to him and hey here's
what we have on you with this
cross-dresser
um I don't know I I think
uh I think the left has a chin I don't
think the right has a chin and if they
do have a chin we definitely don't know
who that chin is so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
thank you
[Music]